when i was in college i didn't really
like could fully see myself in tech but
i was just kind of like
keep going because it was just like a
small part of me that was like i think
this is where you're supposed to be but
it was with my internship at intuit i
was just like wow i can actually see
myself like working in industry
[Music]
hello all and welcome to muko's corner
muko's corner is a show about leading a
life that feels more you in your life in
tech career i'm your host mayuko inoue
and i invite you as always to come on in
sit down grab a drink of choice maybe
it's a green tea or something today and
enjoy the show today on the show we have
maya she's a software engineer content
creator and speaker who aims to inspire
more people to get into tech she's
worked as a full-stack software engineer
at companies like intuit and slack where
she's built features used by millions
also known as maya loves code she has
amassed over a million views across her
various social media platforms where she
creates content about tech software
engineering and her life she's been
featured in khan academy godaddy pro's
documentary series and has been a
co-host for amazon web services so hi
maya how you doing how has your week
been
oh my goodness my week has been actually
long and stressful
oh goodness
yeah i'm working on this new feature and
i'm like reusing this component but
reusing it it's just so tough and i just
keep running into problems and i thought
it was going to be so easy
but other than that it's okay
software engineering struggles for sure
is what it sounds like yes yeah well i'm
so glad to have you on the show this is
actually our very first recording of
2022 so thank you for being my first
guest of the year i've been trying to
get you onto the show for months and we
had scheduling conflicts my camera broke
like it took i think this is our third
try and we're finally doing it so i'm
really excited um maya and i have a lot
of shared like
like commonalities history but we've
never like caused paths so like one of
the things i really wanted to dive into
was just like
just to talk about some of the things
that we we've both been through it'll be
super fun you're kind of one of the few
other people in the tech and lifestyle
space like me there's really only like a
handful of us yeah i think that's also a
really unique perspective that i wanted
to just like chat with you about because
there's really not that many people to
talk about that stuff with yeah no it's
so funny too like the time your camera
broke i'm like i was thinking about the
tv show catfish and i'm like i wonder if
it actually broke
i'm excited to have this conversation
awesome well i think because you know
it's the beginning of a new year right
now we're recording on january 14th it's
like the second week it's the end of the
second week how's your year been so far
i'm curious like if you set any
resolutions like what your intentions
are i feel like now is still the time
that people are thinking about that so
yeah how's your year been so far yeah so
it's like different like categories of
things so i would say health-wise i'm
like checking off each of those goals
like being more intentional about what i
eat yeah
you know i always have a goal of like
going to the gym but i've actually been
going to the gym wow
you're doing it that's awesome
yeah so that has been good
work-wise we have a deadline coming up
and you know like we created this
deadline but it's fast approaching and
like a lot of things are just like
exploding so that's been like stressing
me out
it's like 5 p.m hits and i'm like should
i continue working on this or should i
go live my life like
that kind of struggle all too well yeah
it's like it's funny because it's like
that the thing you said about like
there's a deadline but it's self-imposed
is like i feel like the catch-22 of
software engineering where it's like
people want a
deadline timeline estimate and then as
soon as you give it to them they're just
like okay i'm gonna hold you accountable
for this and you're just like that's not
how coding works like you don't know
what's gonna come up like we're gonna
have an incident who knows like you
really can't do that like this is just
our best guess
like our team are trying to get better
at like creating estimates but i'm like
you know something's always going to
come up but like
one of the best pieces of advice that i
was given because i there was a point
where i was like really stressing about
deadlines too and like my vp of
engineering at patreon was like you know
where you go realistically like
estimates are the most accurate when you
make them and then they just go out of
date like super quickly and it was
really reassuring to hear him say that
because i was just like really you're
not gonna like fire me because i gave a
bad estimate really are you sure and he
was like yeah like that's realistic and
i was like oh
give a sigh of relief i love that and i
love how it came from like a higher up
too just because you know they're ones
that can really lead like culture at a
company so yeah i'm gonna use that yeah
oh please do yeah throw that everywhere
like be like okay come on now but like
we were way more informed now we're
smarter now we know a lot of stuff so
like here's here's like here's a
realistic expectation kind of thing
wait so you're currently at intuit is
that right so i joined slack in february
of 2021 so yeah now
oh awesome how have you been liking it
so far yeah i really like it like some
things that like i've noticed between
different companies is like how the
culture can really change and like slack
a lot people are more like goofy
like they love talking about their side
hobbies and stuff like that which is
something i love and then also like
creating
you know when i was that intuit every
time i would use slack i would be like i
like slack a lot like
this is a great product and now to
actually like be working on it is like
really cool that's really cool and
specifically if i remember correctly are
you an ios developer or like what kind
of are you full stuck because you said
you have full stack experience too yeah
full stack got it okay slack is one of
those companies that like i remember
being like everybody wanted to work
there and i think a lot of people still
do want to work there because their
culture was like so different from
everywhere else
it's it's really like amazing and it's
just like we could be in like a big
meeting like it's on zoom you know
because of the pandemic and all that but
it's like you have like the ceo talking
and people are like making jokes in chat
it's just so crazy and like yeah
everyone's really chill but like still
super passionate and i feel like when
you can find like nice and smart people
like that combination is amazing and
it's just like
it feels great to work with my
co-workers literally like nice and smart
are probably like my two main priorities
in looking for co-workers like
you can't just be smart you can't just
be nice like i need both and when you
find somebody who does both it's like
it's like everything comes together i
feel like
yeah you know that was one of the things
i noticed in the interview process
because i was looking at like fang
companies and other companies like that
but with like when i was going through
the slack interview i just felt so like
at peace and at home and it felt like a
safe environment and you know i feel
like sometimes in interviews you feel
like you just you gotta prove yourself
you gotta prove yourself tell you
everything i know but you know slack at
the same time was like let us know like
you know what you want in a company and
it just felt really equal and you know
that was one of the things i just loved
that's really cool how big is the
company right now so it got acquired by
salesforce but like just like black yeah
slack i would say the last time i
checked was like 3 000 total employees
dang
it's gotten so big
yeah like i talked to people that's been
working there for like four years and
they talk about like all the changes
that happen and they're just like yeah
like i remember we would really just
like push out any type of code there was
like no real process and you know now
things have changed i also used to work
it into it and like i i worked there
around 2014 2015 and that was like when
slack was like just starting to become a
thing like i think my team used hipchat
for a while like atlassian's um
like messaging thing and like nobody
uses it anymore i don't think except
maybe atlassian but i don't even know if
they still make it but i remember we all
used hipchat and it was very similar to
slack but it didn't have threading but
it had emoji reactions and then i think
my manager told me and the intern
because we're like the youngest
i guess or maybe we had the most time i
don't know they were like oh check out
the slack thing and then we made a slack
team for our team and then we found the
jiffy extension and then we're like this
is so cool like you said
gifs like to your co-workers and like
you know now it's like gifts are
everywhere and everyone uses memes and
emoji reactions but at the time we were
so excited and we flooded our slack too
much with gyms that like when it came
time to onboard our team they're all
like
there's only jeff's here like what are
we supposed to do
and it didn't get adopted for like
months after that because we had too
much fun with jeff that's milo like all
at work that's like the way i
communicate like my love language like
there's emotions
yeah like there's like a core set of
them that everybody uses
that like i use over and over and over
again like one that i always use is the
whole like you got it dude like just yes
warehouse
cause
yeah like whenever anybody's just like
hey can you do this for me like i send
it because i'm like that's the best way
to respond instead of being like okay
like yeah
like when my like thank you emoji is not
a basic like thank you it's like a full
little animation thing
it really is it's a method of
self-expression at work which like
is you know that that's what makes work
fun sometimes and i feel like you need
some of that stuff
yeah exactly you know when i was like
trying to figure out like which company
i wanted to work at next like i really
understood the power of having like a
supportive team and also a team that
like genuinely
is not trying to like show up you know
another person like we both went to ucsd
and i feel like that was a whole culture
of ucsd like that hustle that grind like
all of that the dungeon do you remember
gosh the csc dungeon it was so dark
yeah that's where like people would go
write code and all that stuff and like
yeah there was no windows
it was literally underground but you you
know what's interesting like i've talked
to like a handful of other people about
like oh what was your cse labs like and
everybody's like oh it was also
underground and we also called it the
dungeon and so i'm just like
why are these schools shoving these csc
majors underground to code like we need
sunlight like everybody else like we're
also human beings don't
i was just i thought it was interesting
that i was like why is that why are we
all underground like why why can't we be
out in the open with beautiful yes
[Laughter]
exactly some like i think like the
medical school had this like beautiful
library
so pretty like i i oftentimes was just
like like sometimes you had to go to the
csc labs to do your programming
assignments um actually a lot of the
time that you did but anytime that i
didn't have to i would go to like geisel
third or fourth year
because i was so pretty or go to the
biomedical sciences library because it
was so pretty and it's like every chance
i had i would try to leave the dungeon
no that was smart going to the third
floor because the second floor of the
library was always so like hectic so
hectic so many people no view
yeah and i think it was open like 24
hours so people would really like pack a
bag
it would sleep there
i know
like literally like all of us ucsd
students are like so desperate in so
many different ways especially the ones
who study like engineering or stem or
anything
okay wait so click on it yeah
for context yeah we both went to ucsd we
both studied you studied computer
science too right
yeah we both studied computer science we
both worked into it but we never
crossed paths we never met each other
when were you at ucsd
i was at ucsd i started in 2014 and
graduated like 2018. literally like we
eclipsed each other because i was there
from 2010 to 2014. but like oh wow
i think though like we pro like we
probably all had the same professors and
like a lot of the same programming
assignments and stuff i i wanted to ask
like how was your time at ucsd
oh goodness let's start with the
positives you know
yeah let's start with the positives and
then we'll really get into it
like you might have had to dig but there
were some like really amazing people
that i'm still in contact with today
and like even some professors like did
you have professor mia mines or
christina alvarado
those two i really wanted to but i think
they started teaching more of the like
under lower div classes after i left
which was i was so sad because i was
like i have no i think i had one woman
professor but like it was
151 i think it was like introduction to
ai and her class was so hard and i never
like really related to her but i heard
oh um the second one what was her name
oh christine alvarado i heard she was
really like awesome so i was sad that
she has my heart oh
i'm so jealous that's awesome though i'm
glad like what does she teach a lot of
classes so remember data structures and
algorithms i took her advanced one but
she also did cc12 as well and i know you
took that with gary i took 12 with kubay
actually oh did you tutor for gary no i
never tooted for anybody because i had a
really low gpa
that was me
but you see mia mines like she like uh i
took like an extra quarter to do stuff
and all that and um she was like yeah
come tutor for 8a like you know like the
introduction class yeah so even with my
gpa she still took me and it was like
such an amazing time tutoring so
shout out mia
yeah oh my gosh that's like i'm not
gonna name names but the professors who
were like you cannot be a part of the
tutoring program if you don't have above
3.0 did make me feel bad and i felt
really dumb like while i was at ucsd
because of that because all the like the
really smart kids like became tutors and
it was a paid position and they had like
banquets and like off sites and retreats
and it was like an exclusive club
oh i'm like
no i feel that like they kind of felt
like a clique in a way and like i know
some professors they would bring people
in industries like some people could get
jobs if they were like a tutor for a
certain professor
and
we over here were just like struggling
yeah oh totally i think like i only had
maybe a couple semesters where my like
quarter gpa was above 3.0 so it wasn't
even like reachable for me and like you
know well we can say we turned out fine
like we're we're driving we're doing
great
but like easier to talk about now oh
yeah definitely at the time i think we
if you asked both of us we'd be like we
don't want to talk about it like
so so shameful
[Laughter]
but yeah oh that's such a vibe that's so
funny like that's something that like
still kind of irks me to this day
and i think it has actually shaped me to
be who i am of like oh well i wasn't
allowed to be in the tutor space so i'm
just gonna kick ass when it comes to
getting a job and like yeah great career
yeah no ucsd was super super stressful
and also the quarter system like the
quarter system is just so much faster
like after your first midterm it's
really just downhill like it's just
testing seriously and midterm one hits
like week three so then like seven weeks
of the quarter you're just like i hate
my life this sucks and i regret being
cse to begin with yeah and like also the
culture there like if you were really
great at programming you were like a god
like people actually call you like there
was one guy that was like todd the god
you know it's really really good
yeah no way
i'm realizing it's a it's a big
byproduct of being at like a really
large research institution and like i
i've heard now that like ucsd is just
bursting at the seams and they just like
like csc became impacted i don't know if
when you joined it
yeah if it wasn't back to when i joined
i would have gotten and so luckily i
slid in there but like it's impact i
know we did it we made it like we did
but like
now it's impacted and even still even if
you're in the major it's incredibly
difficult to get in and like i don't
know if you remember there was um like a
math cs major and like all these
adjacent ones yeah those are also
impacted because everyone's like i just
need a slice of the pie which like when
we were there i already felt like it was
really competitive and i can't even
imagine what it feels like to go there
now yeah and then like all like the
waiter courses that we had to do cc30
oh that was so hard
did you take compiler construction or
did were you able to like
sneak out of that because i know they
changed their requirements for
graduation i was able to sneak out of it
i would not wish that class on anybody
unless you like it of course which there
are people who like it but i gotta i
actually got a d in that class
yeah actually that was me and cc30
yeah then i realized i realized i was
like if even if i get a d i don't have
to retake it and i
i don't want to take that class by any
means so i i took it i was just like
that's fine by me if i can graduate i'll
take it yeah no okay like i was
wondering when they put that into like
law or whatever that a d was still
passing but that just shows like how
many people want to take these classes
that like a d they're just like keep
going i know seriously
so okay so then you were at ucsd and
then when you graduated did you go to
intuit
yeah girl we're the same
literally the same
did you internet friend okay
i did too okay wait which part of intuit
did you work at so for the internship i
did the one in san diego so i was
working on like turbo tax did you also
oh yeah
this is amazing
seriously
wow okay so you worked at turbo tax for
your internship and then what about for
full time and then full time i came to
the bay area and that's when i worked on
quickbooks live which was like a new
service they were bringing out what
about you i'm the same i did the
internship in san diego and then i did
the rotational program but like they
killed it you know like while i was in
it actually which was really unfortunate
literally like if we were in our it was
like a two-year program right you're
supposed to do like for uh yeah four
rotations six months each and then
during the first rotation they were like
we're pulling the plug and we're all
just like we chose this offer because of
this program and if you're cutting it we
either like we should get compensated in
some way
yeah and like there were some really
vocal people and i was kind of just like
well i kind of like the team that i'm on
so i'm actually okay with it but then um
people advocated for a pay bomb because
they were like if you're gonna take this
opportunity away from us then at least
give us opportunities in other ways
we're and like i think also a lot of
people were like we feel like we're
being underpaid so they give us a salary
bump so i was just like i love that yeah
i was i was like i'm glad that i have
like such cool peers who advocate for
themselves because i'm benefiting from
it too but yeah so i did my first year
post grad at
in turbotax
in san diego and then
my next rotation was at um quickbooks
mobile uh before
qbsc and quickbooks mobile merged
i was on like a very small team
um
for for the mobile app which uh had to
handle both the ipad and iphone apps
which were that code race was so gnarly
like i was yeah oh yeah into it it's
it's so every single one of their
products have gnarly code bases
yeah like
you see comments like don't touch this
we don't know what it does
they're like this one guy built it five
years ago and he's gone now
and uh we don't really know what it does
and it's like but shouldn't you and
they're like yeah yeah we'll get around
to it and we can do tech debt which is
never yeah
exactly but that's i feel like that's
the case at most companies
how was your time into it yeah you know
when i was at like when i was in college
i didn't really like could fully see
myself in tech but i was just kind of
like
keep going because it was just like a
small part of me that was like i think
this is where you're supposed to be but
it was with my internship at intuit and
you know the san diego like office is so
chill and it like really has its own
vibe
and you know with my coworkers i was
just like wow i can actually see myself
like working in industry so i felt like
after that internship i had it even my
junior year just because like my first
two years i was like why would someone
want to hire me like i'm i don't know
calculus like i was just saying all
these like
random things but it was there that i
was like okay like i see the goal i can
do this and that was like really when i
started like believing in myself more so
that's what i really liked about intuit
that is so cool i'm glad the internet
like helped instill that confidence in
you because yes i feel like that's
that's so hard when you're a student and
like until you get that experience where
someone's like i believe in you
yeah it's rough going yeah i remember
with my manager i was like so nervous
throughout the whole time i'm just like
i remember checking in like am i doing
okay and he was like yes like you've
been killing this and he was like as
long as you're learning every day you're
on the right path and shout out paul
like i held on to that and yeah it was
it was really beautiful i think into
also was like the place that instilled
confidence in me too because i think i
was just such like a poor performing
student even though i i literally gave
in my all like it's not like i didn't
care it was just like i really wasn't
bad at it and the way that like tests
happened and programming assignments
happened like i couldn't keep up and it
was really hard but
once i started working especially at the
internship and doing well and i was just
like
i can do like it's like i have like a
other advantage competitive advantage
that i know how to work and like even
though i'm bad at school if i can work
like i mean ultimately i i want to work
after college so
like that was like the light at the end
of the tunnel for me yeah i saw some of
the other skills that i had but like it
just didn't shine in college like
communication like i can communicate to
designers for them to understand where
we're at also pms then also like
documentation like i would always keep
like very detailed notes and it's like
helps other co-workers come up to speed
but you know when you're taking a class
about architecture you know
those skills are not really needed like
you just need to know the difference
between an or an and gate right whatever
you know oh my gosh okay so like one of
the things too that like we recently
were just talking through instagram dm i
think or something was like so i've been
conducting research about like what it's
like to work at like different companies
slash like how do you make career
decisions and actually by the time that
this is out maybe the video is going to
be up but it's a video about like why
does everyone want to work at fang and
you kind of mentioned like oh there was
that pressure for me too while i was at
ucsd so can you can you talk a little
bit about that yeah i think that was
like everyone i talked to their dream
company was to work at fang and like you
know people would be
you know in the dungeon with their
cracking the coding interview books just
like redoing that all night like that
was really the culture and it was kind
of like you know if you worked at those
companies it was like okay like you're
kind of like validated in a sense but
then if you went to like a random
company that someone didn't know or
something like that you know people
didn't get like as excited and things
like that and then even now when i went
through the interview process like so
for me i felt the google interview twice
but then this last time like i put in
the work i studied so much it was
actually crazy and i got like an offer
and everyone was telling me like go to
google go to google do fang but then
like you know there was another part of
me that was like i think i would really
like slack so i even had to go through
that like where do i go type decision
wow so you turned out google for slack
that's like something that yeah i would
imagine a lot of people were like why
would you do that
yeah like i would like to make a whole
video on it because like sometimes
people in my comment section are like
why like why would you ever do that but
it was just like so many different
factors do you want me to kind of talk
about like yeah yeah i'm curious like
what what are some like how did you
decide and like give us a little sneak
preview of what's gonna be in that video
yes i got you
[Laughter]
so like you know i would always hear
good things about slack in the
background but like when i started so i
studied for seven months data structures
and algorithms yeah it was insane and
like the whole goal was fang like even
at my like i had a trello board where i
like organized all of my different like
studying and stuff like that and like
google was in the background of it like
i was manifesting like it was like
everything combined
but like um i'll just hear these great
things about slack like i remember
someone was like oh there's happy black
people at slack and i was like okay
like just randomly like people talk
about that stuff and i was just kind of
like taking it in a little bit but then
it's like when i went through the
interview process so basically the
person who was supposed to be my manager
he worked at a startup that was acquired
by slack and he was just one of like the
coolest people ever you know he was also
black he had like a great personality
like i remember going to the interview
and like when his camera came on like
the preview thing was like his face on
like a caterpillar and i was just like
dying before the interview even started
like was super smart like but also like
you know that smart and kind thing that
we were kind of talking about and like
there was so much diversity like you
know my current team has like um three
black people on my team and like when i
was joining as well like both the team
leads were women and i was just like
what in the unicorn is happening
that's amazing
i mean unfortunately it's amazing
because we would like it to be more
common but like that's really awesome
yeah
and like you know other things as well
like i felt so comfortable in the
interview process but then at the fan
companies like i won't say the fang um
company but like when i got interviewed
for the on site it was just all male
like straight up every single interview
and i was just like you know that
feeling of like you know trying to prove
myself
and then also like um
i did a lot of front end and intuit but
i was still kind of curious with back
end and you know for some companies i
was going to be straight back in or
straight front end but you know with
slack they were just like oh you can do
both like even though they do have
specific titles they're like whatever
part of the code base you want to touch
like go ahead and i was just like great
and even the pay i think sometimes
people think fang pays the most and some
companies were like okay we can match
this but for like the initial offer
slack was like the most you know so
that's something else
yeah to put out there and it was just
like so many different like combinations
of things i also heard at like some
thing companies like sometimes you you
would have to focus on like one thing a
lot just because there's so many
different people there so you might just
be doing like straight css like that's
your specialty and i was like i don't
know if i want to specialize in
something yet like i still want to
explore and figure things out
so and then i was also thinking like
with my team at slack i'm like this is
something so rare like i've never worked
with anyone that looked like me before
and i was like i'm still so young in my
career if two years from now i want to
go to any of these fang they are still
there it would still be the same thing
they're not going anywhere
yes
so those were some of the factors but it
was still super tough like i was back
and forth pros and cons less but i
realized at the time i was going to go
to fang for the name that was what they
had going for them that it was a thing
but then for slack it was so many things
that are like true to maya like to me i
found it there so like even after the
like interviews like the my manager
reached out people on the team like they
all sent emails to me just saying like
we would love to have you on the team
and like those little things i was just
like okay like it feels like it was like
heart and head
situation
where to go
yeah i mean yeah because it's like i
think more and more we're all
i don't know i mean i'm guessing more
and more like we're all trying to find a
place that makes us feel good about
where we work like yeah both about the
work that we're doing but also working
with people that makes us feel good too
because like difficult co-workers i
think is one of the things that's most
stressful about a job
and like if you can work with people who
you enjoy
working with who are really smart who
you can learn from and who are kind and
like really generous with their time and
energy to like help you and work
together and stuff like it just makes
your life infinitely better i feel like
yeah it's like that safe environment to
ask a question like are you gonna be
stuck on this for a day because you feel
comfortable to speak up or is it gonna
be like two weeks just because you like
it's just not that safe space
totally yeah for sure well i'm so glad
you're happy at slack that's i think
that's a really good story for anybody
who's listening or watching who's kind
of torn between two companies like i
think the type of reflection that you
did and like figuring out what really
works for you and what you really need
is ultimately going to be the right
answer
yeah exactly and it's like
you know even if you're in like you're
young in your career like it's like it's
not like you have to stay at a company
for like 20 years like you can always
switch it even in tech it's so common
people stay two years and then they're
on to the next so it's like you'll have
your time to go to whatever company you
want that's so true life is actually
very long and like if you think about
all like if you even if you think about
software engineering is only a 20-year
career which is pretty short compared to
other like professions probably gonna
work at still ten different companies
which is cool yeah
i mean that's another trick to it how
you can get better pay too
they say like if you stay at a company
longer than two years you're really just
missing out on pay which is you know
also insane to think about that i know
yeah definitely well thanks so much for
sharing that i'm looking forward to the
video and also like you know all of your
socials and stuff will be linked in the
description box or the show notes but i
did want to talk a little bit about kind
of your content creation
instagram tick tock youtube stuff
because i mean that's that's kind of how
we met i guess more or less yeah like
that yeah i don't remember exactly when
we started talking to each other or
anything like that but yeah tell me
about that tell the audience about like
what do you do like kind of what what
types of content do you like making um
that kind of thing
yeah like my first video on this on my
like tech channel
it was like my first day at intuit i was
just so like proud of myself and i was
like wow like i made it
so i like took out my camera and i was
just like i just want to film this
moment you know for me but then it was
like later on i was like you know what i
could actually like share this with
people and like i feel like now i was in
a space in my life that i could also you
know talk about my tech journey and
hopefully like inspire people who are
like struggling just like how i was so
that was kind of like the initial you
know thing that got me into it but like
i've always loved like creating videos
and the creation process like i'll just
always do it like for fun like as a kid
so like that was one thing but yeah i
like talking about like you know like my
life as a software engineer like day in
the life type stuff to also just like
giving advice i'm stepping into like
tech reviews a little bit so that's
something i want to do oh yeah
yeah just all things tech software
engineering and also lifestyle too like
like the first couple of weeks of this
year i was kind of like struggling with
like a whole bunch of stress so i'm like
i kind of want to do like a whole reset
routine type of video
so like you know anything i want to
create
for sure yeah definitely i i love this
type of content that you make because
it's like really really helpful for
anybody who's like trying to get into
technology and i also love that you
bring so much of you into all of it too
you tell your own story you talk about
what's actually helped you what hasn't
helped you and you're just like you're
just so like unabashedly you which i
think is awesome
and like i'm so proud to share this
space with you because you know like i
think other youtube verticals and stuff
it's all about competing against each
other but really in our space like the
more different types of people the more
voices we have who share about who they
are and their tech journey and stuff the
better because everyone like you can't
you can watch me and maya like that's
the beauty
of youtube yeah
even my analytics was showing me like we
have a lot of the same viewers it was
like a feature they were trying out and
i was like that makes sense it does make
sense
you've inspired my videos too like i
recently did a video like my computer
science degree in like 12 minutes and
like i watched your video on that and
like someone else's but like yeah i
gotta watch that because we did the same
degree and i'm so curious about your
tastes
[Laughter]
amazing
all the calculus classes we have to take
the 20 series math 20 series seriously
why like why did you really begin
how funny
all right well maya i think that's
actually it for the show so thank you so
much for being on it where can people
find you on the internet yeah so my
youtube channel is after my name maya
bello and then on tick tock twitter
instagram my handle is my love's code so
yeah i would love if you
like
would
subscribe follow comment on other stuff
everything will be linked again in the
description or the show notes so
definitely check her out you can also
listen to this episode of the mooco's
corner app through your favorite
podcasting platform thank you so much
again maya and thank you so much for
listening and hope you have a great one
bye
[Music]